TOOLBARS:
Remember toolbars?
Back in the late 90s and early 2000s, toolbars
were basically synonymous with the address bar of
Internet Explorer. You had toolbars for searching,
toolbars for shortcuts, toolbars for torrents,
and of course, toolbars that you accidentally
installed as bloatware. And some people’s browsers
no joke looked just like this. But, that’s
not too surprising given that basically every
major tech company had their own set of toolbars
from MSN messenger and Yahoo to AOL and ask.com,
and they all seemed somewhat useful. But likely
the most recognizable toolbar of all time is
none other than the Google Toolbar. In fact, I
would argue that the Google toolbar was one of
the main products that initially put Google
on the map. If you’re on the younger side,
you may have never seen the internet before
Chrome, but the truth is that Chrome was actually
a rather late entry into the browser space having
not come out till late 2008. Up until this point,
the only way to easily access Google was to either
install the toolbar or type in google.com into the
address bar, something that I would hope that we
all know is a sin. So, most people resorted to the
former. Fun fact, Sundar Pichai’s first job at
Google was actually to lead product management
for the Google Toolbar back in 2004. But since
then, toolbars have largely fallen out of favor.
To be honest, I can’t remember the last time
I saw someone with even a single toolbar. And
taking a look at Google trends, this seems to be
the overarching trend. Browser toolbars have been
on a downward spiral for nearly 20 years now. In
fact, Google themselves killed off their toolbar
at the end of 2021, so it seems that the era
of browser toolbars is very much over, but why?
It seems that having quick access to the most
popular services that you use right underneath
the address bar would be rather convenient.
Well, it turns out the answer actually has a
lot more to do with maximizing control, power,
and influence over the web as opposed to some
sort of logical reason. So, join me, as we take
a look back at what really happened to toolbars.
TOOLBARS MAKE THEIR DEBUT:
Toolbars obviously got left
behind and the sad reality is that everyday people
are also getting left behind. High interest rates
have made it much harder to afford cars and homes
while high inflation has been eating away at the
savings the people do still have. We wanted
to challenge this reality and help everyday
investors thrive in the modern high interest
rate environment, and that’s why we created Silo,
a modern bond investing platform. With Silo, you
can invest in government and corporate bills and
bonds and earn historically high yields of 4-7%.
This is where all of the biggest companies and
investors have been sheltering their cash
reserves for decades and it seems that
leveraging this opportunity is now more important
than ever. If you’d like to do that yourself with
the protection of $500,000 in SIPC insurance and
$2.5 million in FDIC insurance, please consider
checking out Silo in the description below. But
anyway, taking a look back, the story of toolbars
dates back to the early 1990s well before the
internet or browsers were mainstream. Toolbars,
which were originally called ribbons, were
actually largely popularized by Microsoft
who introduced them into the Office suite. These
ribbons were almost immediately a hit as it made
the software far more useful and accessible. And
as you know, these ribbons are still around to
this day and are very much a critical part of
any Office product. But, while Office ribbons
took off quite early on, it took a lot longer
for browser toolbars to even make their debut,
largely because browsers weren’t really even a
thing yet. Of course, you had the WorldWideWeb
browser that came out in 1990, but it wasn’t until
Mosaic and more notably Netscape that browsers
really started gaining mainstream popularity. This
trend was simply put into overdrive in 1995 when
Microsoft launched Interent Explorer and started
bundling it in with Windows. But, while browsers
were really starting to gain momentum, they were
still quite rudimentary. Here’s how Mosaic looked
for example. It could only display static content
and functionality was largely limited by what the
browser developers were able to pack. As such,
it was only a matter of time until we saw the
world of browser extensibility begin to evolve
starting with plug ins. This of course starts with
the infamous Adobe Flash Player in 1996 and Java
in 1998. These two revolutionized the browsing
experience as they opened the door for everything
from dynamic websites and video streaming to
browser games and more intense enterprise
applications. And as people started getting
used to more capable browsers, they naturally
wanted to do more and more leading us into
the era of browser toolbars. In the late 90s and
early 2000s, we saw the first 3rd party toolbars
pop up but unlike the Office ribbons, these
didn’t exactly blow up in popularity. In fact,
it was quite the opposite until a special someone
stepped into the field: Google. Despite eventually
becoming the world’s largest internet company,
Google didn’t start off with grand ambitions. In
fact, it wasn’t even originally called Google, it
was actually called Backrub. And Backrub started
off as an academic research project that was
more focused on the theoretical side of how
to organize and rank so much data. Fortunately,
the name Backrub didn’t stick around for long but
Google stayed an academic project. In fact, it was
actually originally launched on Stanford’s network
with the domain google.stanford.edu in 1996.
And it wasn’t till 2 years later that Google
was turned into a company but even this wasn’t
too serious. The founders were actually willing
to sell all of Google for just $1 million in 1999
but the buyers passed on the deal. But after this
deal fell through, everything changed. Google was
no longer just a college project with a generous
exit. It was a serious company that needed to
maximize users and revenue but the reality was
that Google was competing in a rather saturated
space. All of the biggest companies including AOL,
Microsoft, and Yahoo wanted to control the
search space. And sure, Google might’ve had
higher quality search results but this only
mattered people even tried it. What Google
needed was a new way to put their search engine
in front of people: enter the Google toolbar.
TOOLBARS TAKEOVER:
The Google toolbar made its debut on
December 11, 2000 with one simple goal: make high
quality search results easier to access than ever.
At first, the toolbar was basically just a search
bar that allowed you to easily search Google from
any website, but over the years, the toolbar
became much more than just that. For example,
after the launch of gmail, users could link the
toolbar with their email and load saved bookmarks
and history. Google also introduced features such
as translation, autofill, and spell checking into
the toolbar. All of these features made the Google
toolbar quite useful but it’s usefulness itself
wasn’t what drove it’s popularity. One of the main
ways that the Google made their toolbar popular
was by making it bloatware. I’m not even kidding,
Google partnered with a bunch of already popular
software companies and stuck deals to bundle in
the toolbar with their software. For example,
they had had such deals with RealPlayer and
even Sun Microsystems. Anyway, as the Google
toolbar started to gain popularity, the big boys
naturally stepped into the arena as well. In 2004,
Microsoft launched an MSN toolbar, AOL launched
a toolbar, and Yahoo even launched a toolbar for
Firefox. And all of these were quite popular.
In fact, toolbars accounted for 12% of search
queries at Google, 18% at Yahoo, and a whopping
42% at Ask. And that’s just the search queres
that were directly being made through these
toolbars. Who knows how many people these
toolbars actually drove to each of these services.
It wasn’t just these giants that were launching
toolbars though. Every internet company you
could think of suddenly had a toolbar. The
one that stuck out to me the most was from Amazon
actually. Before Alexa became the voice of Amazon,
Amazon actaully had a toolbar called Alexa but as
you would guess, not all toolbars were quite as
benign or as helpful as Alexa which leads us
into likely the biggest pitfall of toolbars:
their perception. Throughout the 2000s, toolbars
quickly built up an association with malware,
spyware, and bloatware. Many of toolbars that you
ended up with weren’t even intentional. You were
just trying to download Winrar or uTorrent, and
all of a sudden, the next time you open up your
browser, you’re met with this horrendous blob at
the top. Ironically, Google was vert much part of
the problem but they weren’t too concerned
about that because they were starting to
sense a much bigger problem. You see, Google was
starting to become a bit too successful. In 2004,
they would IPO and just 1 year later, they would
reach a market cap of $100 billion, and this
success started to make the big players rather
nervous. Google was no longer the scrappy startup
with the popular search engine and toolbar. They
had a full slew of products including YouTube,
Gmail, and Android, and with a market cap of
$100 billion, they were very much a big tech
company that was eating into the market shares
of Hotmail, Yahoo, and MSN. And the worst part
about all of this was that Microsoft was that they
were not just standing by and watching it happen,
they were literally enabling it. After all, it was
Internet Explorer’s generous toolbar compatibility
that had made the Google Toolbar so popular in the
first place. As such, it was time for Microsoft to
put their own products first and block out leeches
like Google, and with that, they did absolutely
nothing. The reality is that while it was likely
that Microsoft felt somewhat threatened by
Google’s rising dominance, they never actually did
anything about. Google, on the other hand, did.
GOOGLE PUTS DOWN TOOLBARS:
In 2006, Sundar Pichai,
the leader of Google toolbar development, would
make the bold claim that Microsoft could change
Internet Explorer at any time to threaten Google’s
toolbar business. And his solution to this concern
was for Google to create their own browser and
challenge Microsoft before Microsoft pulled the
rug. Was he actually concerned about Microsoft
pulling the rug or did he just use this fear
as a way to sell Chrome? To be honest, it
was probably more of the latter. You see,
Sundar had already pitched the idea of Chrome
before but his idea was rejected due to cost
concerns. So, it seems that Sundar cleverly
used the Microsoft threat to frame Chrome as
a defensive move as opposed to an offensive
move, and it worked. Chrome would be green
lit and Sundar would be placed at the helm, and 2
years later, we would see the launch of Chrome on
September 2, 2008. From the very beginning,
the intention of chrome was pretty clear:
cut out competitors and grow power for Google, but
to their credit, they did frame this really well.
Instead of saying that Chrome wouldn’t support
any toolbars, they pitched Chrome as a super
clean browser that wasn’t bogged down by a bunch
of extensions. Now, I do want to note that Chrome
didn’t support their own toolbar itself but this
isn’t really a sacrifice. After all, with Chrome,
Google had control over the entire browser.
Despite this clear ulterior motive though,
most people didn’t really care. They were fed
up with toolbars being bloatware and Internet
Explorer in general. So, when Google came out
with a clean browser, it didn’t take long for
people to switch over and for Chrome to become the
dominant browser. Chrome did eventually come out
with their own store for 3rd party extensions
called the Chrome Webstore but they made sure
to differentiate it from toolbars such that no
extension would really be a threat to Google
search. And that was really the end of it. With
Chrome dropping support for traditional toolbars
and Chrome becoming the dominant browser, toolbars
quickly became relic of the past. If anything,
most users were happy to move away from
toolbas as they very much remembered the
nightmares of this. So, toolbars went down as
just something that naturally went obsolete
with evolving technology. But the reality
was that it wasn’t all that natural. It was
Google that made toolbars popular in the first
place and it was Google that eventually killed
toolbars as well with the launch of Chrome,
and that’s what really happened to toolbars.
Something else that has become a relic of the past
is uTorrent. Check out this video to learn more.